hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting
to a video you guys requested shannon
lester
evil week dating advice how to cheat
another feel-good video that i'm just
so excited for uh before i start do not
forget to like comment and subscribe
especially subscribe i'm trying to get
to 15 000
you already know okay
let me let me make sure that the sound
is working on this
you can take from each yeah it is okay
oh my gosh
20 minutes you guys watch longer videos
than i do
if it's not like five minutes it's over
with
oh my god okay
all right sometimes sometimes being good
gets a little boring isn't it more fun
to be bad
how many views did this get before i
start i'm just curious
175 000 okay that's not terrible
isn't it more fun to be the victor than
the victim
i think so and today we're going to talk
about one of my favorite sins
greed not about money not about
possessions
but people what do you do when you can't
just settle for
one man you have to have many many men
today i'm going to teach you how to
cheat and get away with it
you guys are going to get some stds i
swear to god this is the dark side of
having multiple partners that no one
talks about
hpv st you know what
let me just okay but first just want to
remind you that if you want to talk to
me
privately one-on-one about anything evil
or not so evil in your life
find me on my website shaolin lester.com
and also head to shaolin lesser dot com
to shop my new merch line
i've got some great hoodies phone cases
vision boards and crop pops that you
guys are going to
love and be sure to follow me on
instagram at shaolin exo where i let you
guys vote on these topics for evil week
and all of my other videos
genuine question is she in a
relationship
and as you guys know here on the channel
usually
we're talking about positivity being a
bad [ __ ] how to help other people
but like i said sometimes that gets a
little boring
sometimes we have to indulge in the
darker side of life
right because i know you guys are tired
of getting manipulated i hear it all the
time
you're tired of getting cheated on so is
the answer
to become the thing you fear and hate
the most a cheater
it can be i don't subscribe to that as
an overall way to live your life
because here's the thing i have cheated
on a lot of people i have
and cheating does something to you
it splits you into two different people
it does cognitive dissonance is a very
powerful thing cognitive dissonance
means the surroundings like your
circumstances reality
does not align with what you not only
think about yourself
your integrity and your values but most
importantly what you
want to be happening right and it's very
very hard
to be with one person and then have a
side dude
and for the purposes of this video we're
gonna call them mistresses because
it's very offensive that there's no like
male name like misters like what does
that even mean
we're gonna call side dudes mistresses
okay get on board
it's very difficult to be equally in
love with both of them
right there's going to be resentment on
one side or the other and that can be
really torturous for your partner
as you guys have known from being
cheated on so let's say
you don't want to be a cheater let's say
you're starting to watch this video and
you're like i feel bad about myself
okay watch anyway because this is going
to help you
identify a cheater in your own life
sometimes to catch a killer
we got to become a hunter ourselves you
know what i mean we gotta like put on
the cloak of evil
and go inside as a mole in a spy to
smoke out people
and understand because good people
who don't catch bad people kind of bad
people catch bad people
and sometimes that's who we gotta be
i actually agree with this okay not okay
obviously
none of the cheating you guys already
know i don't think cheating is okay
um but i will say that
the more like negative information that
you know the more you can like
point out and like see in other people
ignorance is bliss sometimes
so let's look at the giveaways
for cheating right you have a shift
it's not only a shift in like schedule
it's a shift in behaviors
patterns and most importantly attitude
when i look back on people who've
like cheated on me because you know
it happens in both directions it's not
like only i was the villain it's not
like only i was the victim
i've heard cheating happens at almost
identical rates
i've been on both sides when i look back
it's like the hurtful thing about
cheating is not even that like they
stuck their dick in someone else
it's i don't know that would bother me
my ex-husband said this to me like i
didn't cheat and we didn't cheat on each
other but like we were just talking
about it
and he's like the bad thing about
cheating is that it means you have been
making decisions based on a reality
that didn't actually exist yeah
that's true the truth because you look
back after being cheated on your life
well you question who that person is
because
in your head they're this nice person
who
like would never do something like that
and then the second you get cheated on
it makes you second guess like
everything in your relationship
what a fool you feel humiliated
you feel humiliated and even though
that's probably
not your partner's intent sometimes it
is though sometimes it is
that is the natural consequence because
right sometimes
people are just not great at monogamy
they're weak they're horny
they need a [ __ ] ton of attention they
have a flaccid ego they have poor coping
mechanisms for being alone being bored
being stressed whatever
and sometimes people cheat to get your
attention
so if people fall into the first
category poor coping skills all that
that can be changed it can you can work
on that
but you can't change someone who needs
it needs validation from other people
in order to feel good about themselves
i mean it could prob
i would say 90 of people that need
validation to feel good about themselves
like
can't be changed you know if you're
cheating to like
stick it to your partner that's bad
you can do things that hurt me
accidentally but if you're doing things
to hurt me
purposely there's no coming back from
that but how can you possibly know your
partner's intent
and this is why personally like
intentions don't matter to me
because your intention can be one thing
but the results of your actions are
another
and you never know people's intent like
they can lie about your intent
i doubt most people are 100 honest with
their intentions
but you can't actually know that you
know they're just not and there
shouldn't be deliberate cruelty
is unforgivable you know why because
it's bottomless
where is the bottom of that behavior if
you can cheat on me on purpose and hurt
me you could probably hit me
you could say vicious things could you
kill me could you kill my dog could you
do something terrible like that you know
like
where does that pathology end and a lot
of women
don't know and they just keep going down
this like dead end path
over the cliff into an abyss and they
lose themselves in a toxic relationship
but today we're not going to talk about
people cheating on us necessarily
we're going to talk about cheating on
them but i bring all this up because
look
if you're cheating to hurt your partner
just leave girl
literally just leave just leave because
or if you want to cheat at all you could
leave
call me old-fashioned i don't know
ostensibly
you want to cheat and like not get
caught but if you want to cheat and get
caught on purpose
you're going to play yourself because
then you're the bad guy
so let's say your boyfriend is a [ __ ]
bird and you really have legitimate
reasons for getting revenge on him
and like sticking it to him if you go
out
and take up the mantle of the villain
you blow your position you blow the only
leverage you
have and victim mentality you know we
talk about that usually on this channel
we're talking about good things and
positivity
about how toxic victim mentality is and
how much it sucks and how annoying it is
for everyone around you but it's really
useful when your boyfriend sucks
you know you have to hang on to that
victim narrative that's your power and
that's your leverage
okay but it's not a victim nerd like
i've been in relationships that were
really bad or that like
i allowed things that i never should
have allowed but at the end of the day
like
i allowed that behavior i'm not a victim
if i
contin continue to allow that behavior
if it happens once
fine but
you don't really have any sympathy from
me
if you continue to allow the same
behavior
and i don't expect it from other people
either but let's say
you fall in to the first category of
cheaters i was talking about
people who just kind of like
boys that was always sort of my thing
like i love
boys and i'm boy crazy and i have been
since i was like six and like it
i really think i really think somebody
should have nominated me for some sort
of award for staying a virgin till i was
almost 22. i mean given my libido and
how much i love boys like
that [ __ ] is like in dog years okay i
deserved
recognition from the council of thoughts
you held out the longest from the ratio
of your
again i did but
where was i going with this
what am i talking about cheating
she could have edited this out i don't
really add up my videos either though
so like i said if you are just like oh
you can't kind of resist you're sort of
like a kid in a candy store maybe you're
studying abroad
maybe you guys are like in a
long-distance relationship maybe you
love him but he works a lot and you're
just like
i don't know i just really like making
out with boys okay
first of all keep your goddamn
mouth shut keep your mouth shut two can
keep a secret if one of them is dead as
the old saying goes and no
you probably can't or i'm sure you can
you shouldn't
kill your mistress but you also need to
zip the lip with your friends
right because like
you think you know your friends and you
think they're loyal to you but people
have very
different morality in terms of cheating
first of all i wouldn't die
my friends out to god herself like i
keep their secrets forever
and we got a lot of them but like some
people are not like that like
some people who come from a family where
dad cheated on mom and if they see
cheating it's like
it's like a vietnam flashback or people
that just don't
like that kind of thing i would never
encourage a friend to cheat
that's such a terrible thing to do to
somebody like they cannot
handle it they will sell you out so it's
really
really important to keep your crimes on
the down low
loose lips sink ships you also need to
keep it quiet
from your boyfriend and i know that
sounds obvious i know that sounds
obvious but i get a lot of messages from
you guys where it's like
my boyfriend dumped me or we were on a
break and i went to a club i made out
with this guy and i feel so guilty
because now we're back together should i
tell him i'm like
no are you no
no transparency is
baloney transparency is capitulation of
control
i don't tell anybody everything
certainly not a boy that i'm dating are
you out of your mind
i don't even tell my husband everything
i never i don't know
maybe i'm old-fashioned but i think if
you're married to someone you should
disclose everything to them
like in a relationship fine
but in a marriage like
there's very little in my opinion you
should keep from your partner
tell my husband how old i was i mean he
figured it out but like that to me is
information i don't like to share
i would rather like share my past
results oh
that's just and that's me and that's my
line in the sand you know and like
you have the right to have your own
information stay with within you
when you go out with a guy you don't
have to tell them your whole history you
don't have to tell them that like
you were married or what no one
is owed access to your stories
okay and this is partially true
when it comes to like dating early on um
i would definitely especially as a girl
like
don't talk about your past with guys
they think they want to hear it they
don't
um but and
this is something my boyfriend now
told me that you have to learn to tell
people how to mind their own business
like you're not oh you don't owe anyone
access like you don't have to tell
people everything
but your husband i i feel differently
about that
certainly not your boyfriend because
look you gotta level with yourself
if you go out and you slip up and you
hook up with someone
i had a guy do this a boyfriend i loved
loved
like 10 years ago short
he left me for a stripper but that's the
thing he's like i slept with this girl
down in florida and i was like why are
you telling me this he's like
what i was like when someone cheats
they're either
never going to do it again or they're
going to do it kind of all the time
so which of these categories you fall
into because if you're never going to do
it again
i didn't need to know about it i don't
need to know what
kills your personal growth within this
relationship especially if it's
something that's going to hurt me
because now it's a thing an std does
nobody ever
thinks about stds
he hooked up with did he say a stripper
you don't think that's information that
you deserve to know
okay now it's a thing
in the room that you have to think about
and i'm going to like picture it like
blah blah blah
it becomes an unavoidable data point
but if you're going to do it all the
time
and you're going to leave me for her i
also didn't need to know i didn't need
to know
you could just leave and be on your way
and he's like well it's going to be that
i was like great thank you
you could have just dumped me i didn't
need to know that when i was texting you
and saying all these things you're
sticking into a stripper
thanks i shouldn't talk [ __ ] about
strippers you know i love strippers like
i love them but it's just
it's cliche he was in a band i'm just
like come on
she's like a kid she didn't have custody
obviously you messed out trash
she had like meth eyebrows you know what
i mean you know when you see them
so you gotta zip the lip if you confess
once
it's gonna make it way harder to keep on
cheating and
girl you probably will nope you're
probably cheap
so the second thing you need to do is
foresee the
red flags that are going to pop up in
terms of giving your behavior away
now like i said when people cheat there
are shifts they're on their phone a lot
more
they're making like smiley faces they're
changing their passcode
literally if you're gonna have a life of
crime you should get a second phone
or establish with whoever it is you're
cheating
with that there's like hours and
it's hard you don't necessarily want to
let them know that you
are in a relationship like if you can
help it because they can use that
against you like people will turn on you
they'll blackmail you there's
you know this [ __ ] happens like you
don't want your mistress blowing up your
life
you can do that i don't like this
i don't like this at all
so just be like hey you know when i'm
home at night i turn my phone off make
it up you're lying to one dude lie to
the other who cares
because you need but then you have to
keep track of
all of these lies like you don't think
okay even let's say you decide to live
that life right
you have to keep track of all of the
lies that you're telling these different
people
you don't think that's going to be
emotionally draining having like to use
that mental energy
keep information above and below right
you need to keep
information on a need to know basis not
just flowing out loosey-goosey and you
don't know who knows what and blah blah
blah
so establish some parameters before you
go out like into this
also start having some new activities
and
have two well you're actually going to
only maybe have one
the second one is going to be a variable
activity with a loosey-goosey schedule
so this is what i mean because
scheduling is a big shift in terms of
behavior it's like
she doesn't come home now and like i
don't know where she goes after school
and blah blah blah
so you want to sign up for like two
things say one's like a pottery class
okay you're doing pottery like every day
after work
then you're gonna be like oh i'm also
doing like crossfit and like
it's hard to get in so sometimes the
only classes are like
eight to nine it's so annoying and
actually
do that so that it there's plausible you
know there's
a realism to your lies you're coming
home you're sweaty or whatever it's like
your your body's changing you can like
give
normal accountable details oh my gosh
guys
i'm just gonna be real with you
if you gotta put this much time and
effort
into cheating maybe get a hobby and i
say this like
with love especially to the girls that
are watching this because
if you want to break up with your
boyfriend and like
date someone else that's fine but at
some point your looks are gonna run out
and if you don't have like
skills or like any other source of
validation
like it's gonna be like the second half
of your life is gonna be hard it's not
going to be easy
because you're actually there sometimes
not all the time but again you want to
pick something that the schedule kind of
shifts but not
so wildly it's like oh i went to
crossfit and i spent the night
no like if you if that's what you need
to do if you want to have that big of a
cheat where you're full on spending the
night with another dude
you're going to have to escalate those
lies accordingly you're going to have to
travel for work
you're going to have to like go sleep
with your sister sometimes you're gonna
have to like your
mysterious best friend perry is like
having some sort of like
crisis and you have to sleep at her
house two nights a week
you know work smarter not harder
because then it's gonna give you wiggle
room if he gets suspicious be like babe
i
i know i know just this class opened up
so it's like i'm sorry i'm
i'm gonna go i don't know why it's that
big of a deal like it happened last week
also get your boyfriend involved in
things if he's busy he's not going to be
paying as much attention to what it is
you're doing
right but
and this is truly evil this is evil are
you guys ready for it
you got to start gaslighting him that
is the tool of a chain gas lighting
and so we know what gas lighting is if
you don't it's based on this movie in
the 40s
called gaslight
my coffee table just started vibrating
and that's
a little worrisome all right it's evil
is here
huh and
so this movie and anyway this guy like
adjusts
this like shitty husband adjusts like
the gas flames in the lamps to flicker
and the wife's like these are flickering
he's like
no they're not maybe maybe you're going
crazy maybe we should commit you
to institution and then i can get all of
your inheritance gaslighting
and so we are used to seeing gaslighting
as like a guy calling you crazy but
really it is anyone who tells you that
you are not observing what you are very
much observing
right so it can come in a lot of forms i
don't know where you're making such a
big deal out of this
it's no like there it comes in a lot of
forms so
try to employ it in as many different
subtle and amorphous ways as you can
right and one thing cheaters always do
i've had someone do this to me before
that's so mean that is so mean i would
not wish that in my worst enemy that is
so mean
they're accusatory which is ironic
because like
you really want to like shine a light on
someone's behavior but this is exactly
why they do it it's a distraction and a
deflection technique
so whenever someone's been cheating on
me suddenly they accuse me
a lot of like
things that they themselves are guilty
why were you talking to garrett up in
the pool for two hours what were you
guys doing i'm like
i was just literally doing nothing i you
were at work i don't know
that's because they're doing something
bad and when people are criminals they
see crime everywhere
right so if your boyfriend starts to get
suspicious or even before he does
start to gaslight him this is evil like
this has given me a sick feeling in my
chest because i don't like telling this
but again i want you to use this to spot
people like this in your life
i don't want you to go out and cheat on
people because like i said it splits you
into two
it's really hard on yourself that's what
i was saying
like one you're not gonna feel good
about yourself because you know what
you're doing is wrong
and two like keeping up with all the
lies
good luck society doesn't love a cheater
that's not a fun thing to have to admit
to other people or to yourself
it isn't like you don't sleep great at
night being like i've cheated on people
who trusted me
it's awful it's awful and it's awful to
be cheated on
you know but at least when you're
cheated on you're the victim
when you're the cheater you're the bad
guy and not in like the fun billy eilish
way
really sucky way so
yeah throw your boyfriend off kilter
where have you been
who are you with i don't know who's this
chick natalie you work with i don't know
you're like always talking about her
wifi just go out with her i don't care
then he's gonna feel minimized which is
how we feel when people gaslight us
and he's going to be less likely to
speak up if he sees you doing something
wrong
right so again this is what we need to
look for
when we think somebody is cheating on us
let's see what else
change in schedule yeah come up with
reasons
and it's also really important not to
shift your attitude
towards your partner because also when
i've looked back
on people who have cheated on me and i
see this in questions you guys
give your you say my boyfriend is like
things are really good and it's like
suddenly he became very cold and distant
but he'll have these punctuating moments
of like
so sweet to me so
lovely just like hmm and then
that'll kind of like evaporate and he'll
go back to being distanced like the
psycho repeats and i'm like you know why
because when he's being nice to you
that's because he just heard from his
mistress or he just saw her
doesn't that make you sick that makes me
sick
oh my gosh i don't like this video
this is the problem with watching this
stuff is i swear
like when you look at the world with
like a negative lens
then you see stuff everywhere but just
because you see
like this kind of stuff everywhere
doesn't mean that your perception
is reality to my stomach
but that's the truth and when i look
back
when my high school boyfriend was
cheating on me that's exactly how he
acted that's exactly how
and when i cheated on people that's how
i acted too
it's horrible it's horrible so you have
to be
real careful to keep yourself even
keeled
but guys just be single
just get out of there that's true that's
true
something i hear so often from you guys
is like making excuses for dudes like
well is this girlfriend you can't leave
or blah blah horseshit
if a man doesn't want to be with someone
he's not going to be
same with you guys aren't going to leave
their girlfriend for their side check
i mean we did a whole video about it and
travis scott sidechick was not happy
sorry i'm i am only a mirror
i'm not i am not the problem i didn't
start the fire
okay i am just like warming my hands
next to it
making money off of it sorry
okay um that video is
super feel good ha ha just loved it
so much fun um
was there some truth to the stuff she
said yeah
i'm sure there is but
you shouldn't cheat on someone guys like
at the end of the day do you want to be
a kind caring
and compassionate person or do you want
to be known as an [ __ ]
it's your life but anyways let me know
in the comments
what you think i got right what you
think i got wrong don't forget to like
comment and subscribe especially
subscribe
trying to get to 15 000 this week
i tried for last week i didn't hit it
it's cool though
all right bye guys